gardner minchu parked a bus an old  inmate transport bus to be exact in his  trainer's gym parking lot and lived  there for almost five months of the off  season why he wants a super bowl ring  vacationing like most players do during  the offseason was not his priority  minchu said that it was his little  island he would eat sleep shower there  everything there were obvious concerns  about an nfl quarterback living in a  parking lot for five months he had no  bathroom a wonky ac and a small kitchen  station but minchu is one of a kind  apparently he would stretch in a jock  strap before games wrestle big fish and  he wanted another year of eligibility at  ecu so much that he tried to break his  own hand with a hammer minchu's trainer  said his mobility flexibility strength  and speed has never been better